hey guys so i just got back from ces and
it was such a crazy year this year it
was so insane trying to get from place
to place and i feel like me and jenna
didn't actually film as much stuff as i
hoped but i'm just gonna condense the
two days that i was there into one video
did you have fun at ces i did i had a
really good time you could also see my
footage on its way gently
i also took this pig at 6am in the
casino after i had lost
blackjack we returned to our hotel to
find that there was a pig for sale in
the lobby and i bought it and as we got
on the plane on southwest on the way
home the guy was like oh honey is that
your emotional support pick i was like
yep lost all my money in vegas happy ces
so i'm about to do my first little
thing here maybe a tech talk with aol
i am not going to lie to you i think i'm
still sleeping so i hope i'm able to
form some sentences so we're going to
just know we did a show called hardwired
great show yeah so it was really really
fun we talked about like all types of
technology the first season we focused
mostly on wearable technology which i
love i love fitness trackers i love
anything you want to buy what i did that
day this car is driving itself
it's driving itself go
it was driving itself i promise
holy moly
at you
oh my gosh
this is really awesome
okay oh
what are we doing we're
riding this whip
i think i push this button hey how do
you close the door
just pull it down oh okay
oh it's like a real car a real door
oh this blue seatbelt is awesome
guys hi here put the keys in here you
can start it up so put your foot on the
break
oops
what's it say
just just floor it
how's it feel like we would get so lost
that would be the irony is we would
never make it back here
there's no way i'm taking it out because
i really don't think we could get back i
wouldn't it'll just go around the
parking lot hey guys so it's day two of
ces jenna is finally hear jenna
so we're about to do the twitter keynote
so i'm on a panel with a bunch of other
people and i'm really excited and
this entire ces vlog is basically going
to be me just talking about how tired
ces is extremely exhausting guys you
have no idea
you've seen an um where it was more of a
small community now it's grown so much
how has that changed how you do your
work on youtube i mean twitter is where
i go to have conversations and with
twitter it breaks down that barrier of
uh especially even traditional
celebrities i mean most of these
traditional celebrities that you see
tweeting are the ones sitting there on
their phones tweeting so it breaks down
that barrier for fans to have access to
people and have these real conversations
so we're here at the spa just kidding
we're in the bathroom with arya and
we were looking at my really looked down
there's like here's hairspray
and there's lotion and we took the
mouthwash yeah that's actually right in
our bag we're taking so long and your
frittata's like uh are you done yet
spotting
somewhere that i went i don't even
remember
so i finally made it to ces and then i
hear is that i just see i was like
and i i'm having currently having really
bad vision problems here at vegas so i'm
like uh it is
it is vegas vegas is here yes it is we
have arrived
at 24k
and if you guys ever need to know
anything about vegas like i mean these
are the people to go to thanks so much
we appreciate it yes it's always good to
see you guys we're here we're in the
south hall we're ready to see some
things
something a lot of things
are you are you are you curved or are
you curved i can't wait to put you on my
wall you're gonna be really flushed with
the wall you're gonna look great
so here's the problem i don't watch tv
on tv
so
i mean i like to have a tv you know you
gotta you gotta have it but you don't
ever have to turn it on i like to play
mario kart and nintendo games on a big
television
blue microphones my favorite microphones
ever i wonder if they have any new stuff
i know they have a new pair of
headphones that i've actually been
wanting to check out they're right there
the mofi mofi i think it's pronounced
mofi i've never heard anyone say it in
real life i've been using their
microphones since the beginning when i
first started making videos using my
macbook pro thank you the audio that i
would use was blue
okay we're coming up on our
of course our must visit booth intel we
always do this up every year and here we
are
the booth looks it looks like it's more
airy this year it is cooler it is you
know open i like it
try out the new oculus rift
i might be slightly
a slight germaphobe a little ocd that i
cannot fathom putting that on my face
after knowing how many people here have
also put the same thing on their face
it really makes me uncomfortable i'm
sure they do a good cleansing a good
scrubbing before they put it on the next
person but
i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait so that i
can i can properly desanitize
in the comfort of my own home so we're
gonna go to flear now as you guys
remember last year
flir is the leader in doing thermal
imaging and they came out with the
iphone adapter where you can turn your
iphone into a thermal imaging camera
well they now are coming out with one
for android and for the new iphone so
we're gonna go take a peek
usps why do you crush my packages every
time i get one i don't understand
no we're back here at the flear booth
they've got their new upgraded version
they've not actually said when it's
gonna be released and there's no price
point yet is there oh
it basically just attaches to the bottom
of the iphone and previously the version
it attached at the case so yeah let's
see how hot these people are
you guys are looking really great okay
we're gonna take a photo
you can do panos did you do pianos
before oh yeah so that's that's
stuff that's the pano inside and the
time lapse we added to the app that's
great yeah because before you had to use
separate apps
people need to stop moving
don't move don't move
it's live it's a real time
right there yeah
it feels like call of duty
the thermis
it's a thing it's a thing guys the
weirdest concept for me right now is
trying to realize that the camera is now
down there
it's not right here because you are so
trained when you take a selfie you
automatically go and you look at the dot
now we're here okay ready
oh i blinked look at that i mean 32
degrees celsius
i think i'm warm
wavelength
that's awesome even like i you're
telling me i'm here but that means
absolutely nothing to me and how do i
get out
i'm excited i think we're all excited to
have you take some time away from the
crazy world you see us it's insane i
mean every year it just gets bigger it
gets crazier and now everybody's so
split up i've been here since monday
i just made a shirt hey matt how's it
going hi how are you welcome to the vlog
oh my god i honestly i i stopped doing
this years ago well we're here and
you've got something really cool to show
me this is an amazing thing and this is
beautiful oh hi hey guys i'm sam hagdis
what is everyone doing i think they're
doing good what we have here is the
world's first interactive media player
with an hd webcam
and basically it turns your tv into a
giant android tablet and it works on
pretty much any tv since anything
really hdmi look at
everyone has a tv already they already
have the vehicle you just
give them the power oh my god i might
have to have it
can i get two yeah well just you can go
guys
wait tickets yes it's ice cream
and then of course you can share because
you are blog
you can go ahead and send your images up
to the cloud and now we in the samsung
booth
here's the curve tv have you heard about
the curves
it is
i'm sorry what it's card i'm sorry
what's curve i've been making fun of
curved tvs and i mean i've obviously
seen them but standing right here in
front of it right now it's pretty
awesome okay it is pretty cool careful
i'm sorry
and it has like a nice brushed aluminum
finish okay i think it's nice i think i
like it i wonder how it plays mario kart
so you guys obviously can't see this
because it's 3d uh but it's a glasses of
free 3d it's an 8k television it's
nice it looks good really great